un hito trágico para américa latina en
un escalafón de los países que más
muertes diarias registran por ccoo y 19
por cada millón de habitantes 9 de 10
están en la región se trata de guyana
paraguay uruguay trinidad y tobago
surinam argentina brasil colombia y
bolivia los gobiernos latinoamericanos
intentan contener el virus como pueden
pero brasil sigue siendo el escenario de
un enfrentamiento entre el gobierno
federal y las autoridades locales a
pesar de registrar más de 450.000
muertos el presidente amenazó con el uso
del ejército si se imponen nuevos
cierres más que una obligación y un
deber estoy seguro que las fuerzas
armadas actuarán dentro de las líneas de
la constitución y si es necesario espero
que no sea necesario y que volvamos a la
normalidad
lo contrario sucede en argentina donde
el presidente alberto fernández
endureció por nueve días desde el pasado
viernes las restricciones para afrontar
la segunda ola de coronavirus que sin
embargo dejó un record de contagios este
jueves con más de 41 mil en colombia el
gobierno extendió por 90 días más la
emergencia sanitaria y el país registró
un récord de 25 mil 92 contagios además
el mandatario pidió a la sede que actúe
de mediador para llevar más vacunas a
los países en desarrollo la mejor manera
de atender esta situación requiere un
fortalecimiento verdi no sólo del
multilateralismo para que haya un
sentimiento de equidad para que la
estrategia kóvacs pueda avanzar para que
tengamos herramientas de financiamiento
para el desarrollo en bolivia la
situación en cochabamba y santa cruz se
deteriora ambas carecen de oxígeno
medicinal las uci están saturadas y
hacen falta medicamentos y en uruguay el
gobierno nunca ha impuesto en
confinamiento obligatorio y se abogó por
una libertad responsable de sus
ciudadanos lo que puede explicar en
parte que el país esté dentro del
con más muertos por cada millón de
habitantes